al final lo más extraño sucedió
el pasado 9 de marzo de 2022 tuvieron
lugar las últimas elecciones
presidenciales de corea del sur unas
elecciones que amenazaban con romper
toda una tradición histórica en la joven
democracia surcoreana la alternancia de
gobierno entre conservadores y
progresistas cada 10 años pero esta vez
queridos amigos amigas las cosas fueron
diferentes os hemos hablado ya de ello
en las claves de la semana el boletín
que recibís todos los que formáis parte
de la comunidad de visual política en
patera la corea del sur acaba de
experimentar todo un volantazo político
cinco años después los conservadores
regresan al poder y no lo hacen con un
candidato cualquiera visteis este vídeo
[Música]
ha sido la respuesta a la victoria de un
shock
atentos pero un momento antes de
continuar la guerra de ucrania ha hecho
que los bancos centrales de todo el
mundo también den un volantazo monetario
tras más de una década de políticas
monetarias ultraexpansivas y enormes
programas de gasto público la inflación
de los países desarrollados ha escalado
hasta su mayor nivel de los últimos 40
años esto ha hecho que ahora los bancos
centrales comiencen a tomar cartas en el
asunto la pregunta es hasta dónde
escalarán los tipos de interés para
responder a esta pregunta no te pierdas
el último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido
el canal de información financiera de
mutuactivos con el que colaboramos os
dejamos el enlace abajo en la
descripción dicho esto arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hace apenas 12 meses le hubieran
dicho a iun que un año más tarde se
convertiría en presidente según aseguró
que se habría echado a reír el
presidente electo surcoreano es todo un
outsider de la política hasta marzo del
2021 fue el fiscal general del país
nombrado por cierto por el propio
presidente saliente mucho y todo un
producto ist
[Música]
como fiscal general junts oriol fue
conocido por ser implacable contra la
corrupción de hecho fue el artífice del
encarcelamiento de dos ex presidentes
surcoreanos lee myung bak y parkour cne
que fueron acusados de prácticas
corruptas como sobornos y tráfico de
influencias sin embargo tal y como
veremos eso no fue lo que le hizo ganar
las elecciones una victoria por cierto
lograda por un estrechísimo margen el 48
56 por ciento de los votos frente al 47
83 por ciento de su contrincante
progresista menos de un punto de
diferencia menos de 250.000 votos
ahora bien que explica que se haya roto
la histórica alternancia de gobierno
cada 10 años porque münchen in se ha
convertido en el primer presidente cuyo
partido ha perdido la confianza de los
surcoreanos tras el primer mandato que
futuro se avecina en la península de
corea pues bien veámoslo
la herencia de mundo
[Música]
un chelín se presentó a las elecciones
del 2017 con una serie de promesas
quizás demasiado grandilocuentes y
arriesgadas para un mandato de cinco
años recordad que en corea del sur no
existe la reelección presidencial
m
prometió llevar a cabo una completa
renovación social económica y política
aquí por ejemplo incluye a terminar de
una vez por todas con las estrechas
conexiones entre la política y los ché
bolt los grandes conglomerados
empresariales de corea del sur también
prometió trasladar la oficina del
presidente fuera de seúl terminar con la
energía nuclear civil y las dos cosas
más importantes solucionar el grave
problema de los precios de la vivienda
que hay en seúl y su área metropolitana
y conseguir de una vez por todas la paz
con corea del norte
[Música]
cinco años después ninguno de estos
grandes objetivos se había cumplido
totalmente e incluso podríamos decir que
teniendo en cuenta sus propias
expectativas su gobierno ha sido un
fracaso ni siquiera logró cumplir una
promesa menor como es trasladar la
oficina del presidente fuera de según
algo que por cierto su propio partido le
echan cara al nuevo presidente cosas de
la política y unnim o un chocan por el
traslado de la oficina presidencial los
legisladores del partido democrático
cuestionaron en la reunión la prisa y
algunos insinuaron que podría tener
razones no reveladas para no querer
mudarse a la casa azul como por ejemplo
el feng shui claro que esta es la
cuestión más anecdótica en el caso de la
política energética por ejemplo mucho
más trascendente en 2017 nada más llegar
al poder un chain anunció un plan para
eliminar progresivamente la energía
nuclear del país terminaremos con el
plan de generación de energía nuclear y
allanaremos el camino para una era libre
de energía nuclear cancelaremos los
planes existentes para construir nuevas
plantas y no extenderemos la vida útil
de las centrales nucleares mountain
qué mal envejecen algunas hemerotecas
porque claro con los altísimos precios
del gas natural y el petróleo y con el
carbón también por las nubes las cosas
cambiaron radicalmente el propio
gobierno de munt de repente parecía
abanderar la campaña pro nuclear el
ministro de comercio y energía de corea
del sur visitó la central nuclear de
janón en la región de gangwon y pidió
que se complete en rápidamente los
reactores nucleares en construcción
sufriendo una relajación en la política
de eliminación gradual de la energía
nuclear frente al aumento vertiginoso de
los precios del combustible que sí desde
luego rectificar es de sabios pero no sé
en sólo cinco años y después de haber
sido tan categóricos no sé que
reconozcan por lo menos entonces que
estaban equivocados no pero esperad
porque no hemos hecho nada más que
empezar por ejemplo es cierto que su
política hacia corea del norte ha
supuesto el mayor periodo de estabilidad
militar en la península de corea desde
la salsa en policy de finales de los
años 90 pero al final salvo por sus tres
cumbres kim jong-un y las dos de trump
en las que actúa como mediador los
resultados no han ido mucho más allá
habéis visto el vídeo no pues eso
durante la presidencia de munch en corea
del norte continuó su campaña de
provocaciones constantes por ejemplo
pyongyang lanzó decenas de misiles de
diverso rango continuó insultando a las
autoridades del sur en sus medios
estatales e incluso pocos meses después
de llegar al poder probaron una bomba
atómica de hidrógeno eso sí esto último
las pruebas nucleares sí que se han
detenido en seco la península de corea
lleva cuatro años y medio sin ver una
sola detonación nuclear claro que
también puede ser que simplemente esa
fase del programa atómico norteño ya
fuera completada la guinda del pastel se
vivió en junio de 2020 cuando corea del
norte hizo saltar por los aires ojo de
forma literal la oficina de enlace
intercoreana de que son un símbolo del
diálogo entre las dos coreas desde
entonces los progresos diplomáticos
entre ambas coreas se congelaron
por supuesto a pesar de sus promesas muy
no logró cerrar un acuerdo de paz que
formalmente ponga fin de una vez por
todas a la guerra de corea
[Música]
porque si para los que no lo sepáis la
guerra de korea no terminó oficialmente
en 1953 ese año se firmó un simple
armisticio un alto el fuego así que
técnicamente los dos países continúan en
guerra pues bien el caso es que a pesar
de sus promesas común tampoco consiguió
ese tanto diplomático y sabéis que casi
que mejor mejor no imaginar las
concesiones que hubiera tenido que hacer
para conseguir ese papel por último para
concluir esta lista de grandes fracasos
políticos o promesas no cumplidas
tenemos quizás la cuestión que más ha
pesado en la derrota del candidato
oficialista la política de vivienda un
tema sobre el que ya os hemos hablado
aquí en visual político desde entonces
hasta las elecciones pasaron unos dos
años y las cosas no sólo no mejoraron
sino que no hicieron más que empeorar
fijaos
[Música]
el precio medio de la vivienda en seúl
que es el área más tensionada se ha
incrementado en un 35 por ciento desde
que münchen llegó al poder y alrededor
de un 50% desde 2015 y en algunas zonas
de la ciudad se ha más que duplicado
para que os hagáis una idea esto supone
que un surcoreano que se quiera comprar
hoy un apartamento normal de unos 82
metros cuadrados en seúl tendría que
apoquinar de media más del 970 mil
dólares cuando sólo tres años antes en
2017 es el mismo apartamento y hubiera
costado unos 590 mil así que claro
noticias como ésta no resultan nada
sorprendentes
admite el fracaso de su política de
vivienda bueno al menos en este caso si
lo han admitido algo es algo como os
podéis imaginar esto ha decepcionado
muchísimo a la gente joven que confío
fervientemente en mundo en 2017 quizás
no os acordéis pero se le describía casi
como el obama surcoreano desde luego
aquí en visual político no nos ha
sorprendido nada de lo ocurrido la mayor
parte de las medidas que tomó un mundo
estaban dirigidas al limitar la demanda
y muy pocas a incrementar la oferta de
viviendas pues bien estos han sido en
definitiva los grandes errores que han
terminado provocando un cambio de rumbo
histórico en corea del sur- un cambio de
rumbo eso sí que ha llegado por los
pelos y la verdad con poco entusiasmo
por parte de los surcoreanos como se ha
dicho pero ahora la cuestión que podemos
que tenemos que plantearnos es qué
planes tiene y un socio para corea del
sur pues bien veámoslo
a
que le espera
la victoria por la mínima de iun soy yo
la amenaza con convertirse en todo un
torbellino para la política surcoreana
para la política interna pero también
para el exterior y es que si hay algo
que caracteriza a iun es precisamente
que se trata de un personaje muy
peculiar pero vamos peculiar de narices
y un sol se declara abiertamente anti
feminista y en la campaña le gustaba
jactarse bello también pertenece a la
congregación cristiana protestante de la
joy de fútbol church hablamos de una
congregación religiosa de unos 800 mil
miembros que es una de las más
conservadoras de korea y cuyos líderes
encabezan los movimientos anti lg en el
país por otro lado el ex fiscal general
es en lo económico seguidor de las
teorías de misses y fridman en cuanto a
la defensa del libre mercado es un firme
partidario de la desregulación y los
impuestos bajos y de hecho se espera que
ponga el mando de la economía del país a
un perfil técnico que se aproximó en
estas ideas
[Música]
pero concretamos un poco más todo esto
que os hemos contado cuáles han sido los
principales factores que han contribuido
a la derrota del oficialismo tras la
presidencia de munt así que ahora la
pregunta es cuáles son exactamente las
propuestas del nuevo presidente para
afrontar todos estos retos pues bien una
de las políticas que más ha defendido
durante la campaña fue la de apostar de
nuevo por la energía nuclear si el
gobierno de un canceló la construcción
de varios reactores ahora el nuevo
presidente considera que la energía de
los átomos es la mejor forma de hacer
que corea del sur consiga durante
décadas energía abundante limpia y
barata de hecho cuando nombró su panel
de expertos del comité para la
transición presidencial se pudieron ver
varios nombres de expertos en energía
nuclear toda una declaración de
intenciones
[Música]
respecto a la vivienda otra de las
grandes preocupaciones sociales del país
iuc se ha comprometido a impulsar la
colaboración público-privada para
construir 2 millones y medio de
viviendas a lo largo y ancho de toda
corea durante sus cinco años de mandato
de todas ellas 1,3 millones estarán en
seúl eso por el lado de la oferta por el
lado fiscal y un dice que hará justo lo
contrario de lo que ha hecho muy
aliviará las restricciones a las
hipotecas y reducir el impuesto sobre
las ganancias de capital también ha
propuesto revisar el impuesto de bienes
inmuebles para los propietarios
múltiples para así reducir el precio de
los alquileres
este es un tema que en korea últimamente
acapara toda la atención pensar que
según la confederación coreana de
sindicatos un surcoreano medio de unos
20 años tardaría de media un siglo en
terminar de pagar por sí solo un
apartamento normal en seúl todo un siglo
de hecho según una encuesta del general
business y el instituto de opinión de la
sociedad coreana uno de cada cuatro
votantes cree que la estabilidad del
mercado inmobiliario es el mayor reto
del nuevo presidente
[Música]
pero es que aquí no termina todo coria
es un país con una política exterior
complicada el gobierno coreano tiene que
lidiar con su vecino comunista del norte
y hacer un delicado equilibrio en las
relaciones con china japón y los eeuu un
equilibrio que no pocas veces se
convierte en todo un quebradero de
cabeza pues bien todo apunta a que el
próximo gobierno dará un bandazo en su
política exterior para volverse más por
eeuu y también pro japón lo que
evidentemente puede enfriar algo las
cosas con china sin ir más lejos el
nuevo presidente defiende cosas como
aumentar las baterías antimisiles sat
estadounidenses un despliegue que ella
le costó a corea sufrir todo un boicot
comercial y turístico por parte de china
reconstruir el alianza corea eeuu y
fortalecer la alianza estratégica
integral al tiempo que compartimos los
valores fundamentales de la democracia
liberal una economía de mercado y los
derechos humanos desarrollar e
relaciones bilaterales de respeto mutuo
entre corea y china y crear una relación
corea-japón orientada al futuro yoox
onion pero vale a estas alturas del
vídeo ya se lo que muchos estaréis
pensando
demonios pasa concurre del norte pues os
recuerdo la reacción de pyongyang
como todos los presidentes conservadores
y un es partidario de volver a la línea
dura con pyongyang en este caso incluso
es partidario de intentar que eeuu
despliegue más armas estratégicas en
korea aunque también ha dejado claro que
está dispuesto a continuar con los
diálogos de paz la verdad es que haga lo
que haga lo más probable es que veamos
constantes tiras y aflojas entre las dos
coreas que por otra parte es lo que ya
viene siendo habitual desde hace décadas
o quizás no quién sabe en korea el grado
de imprevisibilidad es siempre bastante
alto por último si os parece echemos un
vistazo a las medidas económicas que el
nuevo presidente ha prometido las
medidas con las que espera que corea del
sur- recupere la vitalidad económica que
tenía antaño atentos
y un anunciado una lucha sin cuartel
contra la inflación reducir la
burocracia y la economía con hasta 80
regulaciones menos para las empresas y
flexibilizar el mercado laboral por
ejemplo para que los trabajadores puedan
trabajar más horas extras algo que
limitó el gobierno de munt también ha
prometido colaborar con samsung para
estrechar la brecha que actualmente esta
empresa tiene respecto a la taiwanesa de
smc el mayor fabricante mundial de
semiconductores esto es algo que el
nuevo presidente considera estratégico
tanto desde el punto de vista económico
como desde el punto de vista de la
seguridad nacional
ya os lo hemos contado tanto envasados
vídeos como en boletines de patrón los
semiconductores son algo así como el
santo grial para las economías de taiwán
y de corea y en general para las
tecnologías avanzadas del siglo 21
[Música]
y ya a partir de este punto en las
cuestiones restantes los planes de iun
son de momento poco claros así que en
visual política estaremos
particularmente atentos a cómo se
desarrolla este aparente volantazo
político con el que corea del sur ha
pasado de tener un presidente al que
comparaban con obama a otro al que
comparan con ronald reagan sólo el
tiempo nos podrá decir si realmente esto
es o no una exageración de momento te
pasamos el turno a ti si a ti con lo que
has visto crees que el nuevo presidente
podrá corregir los principales problemas
de corea vivir a cora del sur y una
especie de renacer económico tal y como
vaticina hyung que sucederá con las
relaciones con china y corea del norte
déjanos por aquí abajo tu comentario y
si te ha gustado este vídeo no olvides
darle al botón de like y suscríbete a
visual polític para no perderte ninguna
de las novedades que están por llegar
una vez más gracias por estar ahí con un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]